In prior lessons
Paco learned how to use
the local
development environment
and unfold
the census landing page.
In this lesson
we will add on functionality
to Paco's application and
explain various important points
for developing applications
with micro-framework WebApp2,
created especially
for Google App Engine.
Paco can also use
other frameworks
like Flask, Pylons or Django
to create his application.
Given that WebApp2
is included with SDK
and is easy to understand,
we will use it
as a starting point
for the census application.
By using a framework,
Paco not only avoids
implementing many
low-level details
to processing http requests,
but he also acquires methods
for organizing root code
for the application.
When we created
the census landing page,
Paco included various handlers
in the a.yaml file.
The first of these establishes
that all the routes
that begin with /assets
will serve as static files
from the static file.
The second one
sees that any other route
delivers the index.html file.
After assigning the Python code,
that should execute to resolve
each of the suggested scenarios
in the census application,
Paco needs to make
a small modification.
The index.html
will only serve
in the /. route.
The rest of
the application routes
will be managed by script
that we will build with WebApp2.
The parameter we pass
to this directive
represents the app attribute
in the Main module.
Later on, Paco creates
the .main.pi file
and defines the WSGI application
in charge of attending requests.
WSGI is simply a popular
protocol
among the Python CGI
applications, that makes it easy
to move them between platforms.
The WSGI application builder
receives a list of instances
of route WebApp2 objects
as a parameter.
These objects serve
a similar function
to the app.yaml file handlers.
They allow us to define
the code fragment,
normally one class,
in charge of implementing
the correct logic for each route
in the application.
For example,
Paco's first route
assigns the identity page class
to the /identity route.
We will call this process
Routing.
The additional name parameter
allows Paco to name each route.
This way, when one handler
needs to call another,
from another, Paco will only
need to use this name
and will avoid specifically
including routes like /identity,
which tend to change over time.
We can define as many routes
and handler classes
as necessary.
The goal is to maintain
the logic of the application
as clear and simple as possible
and to not assign
too many responsibilities
to just one request handler.
By analyzing the wideframes
for the census application,
we will initially create
three request handlers.
Identity Page:
for attending matters
relating to user identity.
Question Page:
is charge of question flow.
And Result Page:
in charge of presenting results.
Each request handler
is responsible
for completely handling
the http request,
manipulate data
and turn in an answer
in html, xml, Jason
or whichever format
is appropriate in our case.
With the predetermined
configuration,
the moment
an http request is received,
webapp2 will instance
the defined class
in the routing parameters
previously mentioned,
and will search for a module
with the name of the verb
http used
to make the request
in the class.
Remember that
the most common verbs
in applications that serve
html content are Get and Post.
For this reason,
our request handler
needs to respectively
implement the methods
IdentityPage Get
and IdentityPage Post
to correctly
attend the requests.
To better understand
how all this works
Paco will implement an initial
version of the methods
IdentityPage Get
and IdentityPage Post.
This implementation will print
the initial html code
from the application forms
upon receiving a Get request,
and the data sent on this form
upon making a Post request.
In another lesson
we will learn how to work
in a organized way
with the html code.
For now, Paco will save it
in a variable
and will deliver it directly
to the client in the answer.
This is done using
the self.response property,
over which
variable content is written.
With this property,
Paco can also change
other attributes of the answer.
Like for example,
the character codification
or the type of content.
Given that the predetermined
value is txt.html,
it's not necessary in this case.
WebApp2 also makes
it easier to access the data
sent in the request.
Accessing these parameters
is as easy
as accessing the attribute
self.request.GET
in the case of Get requests,
and self.reques.POST
for Post requests,
or simply
self.request.params,
which combines
the Get and Post variables.
We will learn in another lesson
how to use some
extras included in WebApp2,
such as the session
or internationalization modules.
But for now, we guarantee
that Paco's application
presents the correct
html format in each Get request
and presents the sent data
in each Post request.s
To test this,
Paco opens his navigator
and goes to this address.
Everything functions as hoped:
WebApp2
instance request handler,
defined by the class
IdentityPage
and yaml Get module
by printing the html
that corresponds
to the census page
identity information.
Now, all that's left is to fill
out the form information
and click on Send
to test the Post method.
Perfect.
The data sent from the form
are now printed
upon making the Post request.
Discover other important aspects
of developing applications
with WebApp2
by downloading the code
from this lesson.
Try it in your SDK,
upload it to Google App Engine
and experience creating
new request handlers.
Don't miss out
and keep programming!